bonsoir réalité post merci d'être avec
nous alors pas que des nouvelles
réjouissantes toutes les 12 minutes
nuitées jour un francilien est admis en
réanimation
c'est vrai que dit comme ça on prend la
mesure de la réalité
comment on va pouvoir gérer ce flux de
patients peu de patients en
ile-de-france alors la première chose
qu'il faut se dire c'est qu'il ya une
hétérogénéité en seine saint denis par
exemple
à l'heure où j'ai quitté le service il y
avait aucune place de réanimation pour
les patients qu'ovide à l'autre de
l'autre côté de lait de france si on va
dans les yvelines
par contre il ya un taux d'incidence qui
est quasiment moitié moindre et plus de
lits donc ça oblige déjà dès aujourd'hui
à réaliser en fait des transferts c'est
à dire que tous les patients de
seine-saint-denis qui sont atteints par
le cos vide et qui doivent être
hospitalisés en réanimation sont
hospitalisés loin de la seine saint
denis et jusqu'à l'autre bout des
yvelines donc les transferts à
l'intérieur de la région sont déjà la
seule soupape de sécurité dont on
dispose actuellement pour gérer la
situation
il sort est entre guillemets par la
disparité qui existe encore entre les
départements a effectivement oliveira on
a parlé de ces transferts des dizaines
voire une centaine de patients
transférés c'est une solution viable à
court terme seulement c'est probablement
même single shot on peut faire une fois
ce genre de choses mais on peut pas tous
les jours entreprendre de mettre des
dizaines de patients dans des trains
pour aller vers la province
d'abord parce que les capacités
d'accueil en province vont rapidement
être saturé et puis ensuite parce que la
logistique à mettre en place pour
transférer ces patients est extrêmement
lourde vous montrer des images et
maintenant tout le monde à l'habitude de
voir des images de réalisation et chaque
fois qu'on voit ces images de
réanimation il ya une deux trois
personnes autour du patient et on
comprend bien que le transfert doit se
faire avec les mêmes règles de sécurité
que la réanimation donc avec beaucoup de
personnel et beaucoup d'encadrement
d'autant plus que on fait s'enchaîner au
cours de ces transferts des périodes à
risque chaque fois qu'un patient de
réanimation est passé de son lit à un
brancard puis du brancard à une
ambulance puis de l'ambulance à l'avion
ou aux trains etc
on prend un risque majeur chaque fois
parce qu'on peut accrocher un fils on
peut accrocher un tuyau et que la vie de
ces patients est suspendu à ses fils et
à ses tuyaux donc c'est très complexe
d'un point de vue logistique et c'est
périlleux exigeants en ressources
humaines
donc c'est pas si simple que ça
d'imaginer qu'on va transférer des
dizaines et j'ai du mal à croire qu'on
puisse envisager de transférer des
centaines de patients alors en cause
peut-être notamment 1 2 ce fut très
tendu les variants là encore pas très
encourageant les vétérans n'a pas caché
son inquiétude en disant qu'ils étaient
plus contagieux et plus dangereuse c'est
votre avis professeurs aussi vous le
constater sur le terrain alors de toute
façon il n'y avait aucun doute sur le
fait que à court terme dès son
apparition le vario anglais serait amené
à remplacer totalement le variant
international kg c'est comme ça la vie
la vie des la vie des virus le plus
virulent prend la place prend la place
des autres on était sûr qu'il était plus
contagieux raison pour laquelle il
devient prédominant et malheureusement
des études récentes laissent à penser
qu'ils pourraient aussi être associée à
une plus forte mortalité donc les deux
éléments qui caractérisent un virus
c'est d'une part sa contagiosité
d'autre part sa mortalité et on a
malheureusement l'impression avec ce
virus qu'on perde sur les deux registres
qui sont les profils des personnes
admises en réanimation vers l'est de
mortalité est ce qu'il y à davantage de
jeunes qui sont touchés désormais à la
fois peut-être parce que les plus vieux
se font vacciner parce que peut-être que
ce variant attaque davantage les
personnes plus jeunes
alors vous avez raison il ya deux
évolutions la première c'est que
finalement on arrive aujourd'hui à une
surcharge des services de réanimation
avec une surcharge à un peu moindre des
services d'urgence les patients sont
gérés en amont de l'hôpital plus
longtemps on a même des patients qui ont
l'oxygène à la maison la plupart des
passions les moyens de surveiller
l'oxygène dans le sang à la maison dès
qu'ils sont malades et en fait on a
intervient nous pour les transférer à
l'hôpital à la limite quand vraiment
c'est plus possible de les maintenir à
domicile et ce qui fait que le taux de
patients arrivant à l'hôpital qui a
besoin de la réanimation est un taux qui
est plus élevé alors effectivement on a
plutôt maintenant tendance à avoir moins
de patients âgés et très âgées d'abord
parce qu'ils ont été vaccinées ensuite
parce que les plus fragiles donc déjà pu
la maladie lors des débats qu précédente
mais par contre et c'est important de le
savoir il ya de nombreux patients plus
jeunes qui sont hospitalisés qu'ils
soient hospitalisés en réanimation avec
des formes graves et effectivement la
plupart du temps on retrouve des
facteurs favorisants qui sont maintenant
bien connus comme en particulier
l'obésité chez ces patients merci
beaucoup en tout cas à frédéric
lapostolle nous avons accordé ces
quelques minutes dans votre emploi du
temps chargé on imagine merci à vous